les grands de ce monde sont à la
bastille ce soir pour l'inauguration de
l'opéra en avant-première du sommet d
industrialiser les pays pauvres
réclament un sommet nord-sud pour eux
les hommes naissent et demeurent libres
et égaux en droit ce matin le début des
cérémonies du bicentenaire dans un
hommage sobre à la déclaration
universelle des droits de l'homme
33 chefs d'état y était le chancelier
ouest-allemand foule insiste sur la date
et l'environnement il est l'invité de
christine ockrent un chef d'état par
jour en exclusivité sur antenne 2
l'incroyable et longue cavale de trois
malfaiteurs près de vichy il cessa caché
dans une charrette de poing au nez et à
la barbe des gendarmes
après la tragédie le deuil pour les
familles des 14 victimes du tueur dément
à lux yole dans le doubs les obsèques
auront lieu demain
madame monsieur bonsoir
à paris on a commencé aujourd'hui à
écrire quelques pages supplémentaires de
l'histoire de france
les cérémonies du bicentenaire ont
débuté ce matin mais l'information de
l'après-midi et politiques du ballet
diplomatique qui se déroule dans la
capitale depuis 24 heures a émergé
l'idée d'une conférence nord-sud qui
pourrait suivre le sommet
désindustrialisé l'idée émane de rajiv
gandhi l'indien d'hosni moubarak que
l'égyptien d'abdou diouf le sénégalais
et de carlos andres perez le vénézuélien
françois mitterrand est d'accord pour
essayer de concrétiser le projet mais
d'abord la fête il y à une heure les
grands de ce monde
ils sont 33 étaient conviés à
l'inauguration de l'opéra bastille l'un
des grands travaux du premier septennat
de monsieur mitterrand soirée de
prestige en présence d'invités triés sur
le volet un tour à l'opéra martine
laroche joubert
bruno gex
par ordre d'entrée en scène c'est une
diva margaret thatcher qui gravitent en
avance les marches de l'opéra bastille
presque tous les grands ténors de la
politique internationale sont ce soir au
rendez vous george bush le président des
états unis et barbara sa femme
brian mulroney le premier ministre
canadien cory aquino
la présidente des philippines le chef
d'état du bangladesh général ershad
suivi du premier ministre indien rajiv
gandhi
dernier arrivé françois mitterrand en
tout plus d'une trentaine de chefs
d'état et de gouvernement en 2007 en
invités privilégiés qui pendant quelques
minutes et jus d'orange à la main
échanges qu'elle peut propos pas de
fausse note
dehors sur la place de la bastille le
coeur des anonymes
il ne voit pas grand chose et sont un
peu déçus une dizaine de milliers de
personnes pour scruter des voitures
vides
seul le petit génie est bien placé début
du concert
après les couacs de sa mise en chantier
l'opéra bastille enfin lève le rideau
hall
il n'y a aucune raison d'être jaloux de
ceux qui étaient aux meilleures loges
puisque ce soir antenne 2 vous offre
cette soirée de gala
ce sera juste après ce journal le
spectacle est signée de bob wilson sous
la direction de georges prêtre avec
l'une des plus belle pléiade d'artistes
au chômage ou d'anderson teresa berganza
placido domingo
ajoutons barbara hendricks ou ruggero
raimondi en chine à cuba mais on a
procédé aujourd'hui à des exécutions
capitales en france à paris on a célébré
ce matin sous un ciel d'azur au
trocadéro la déclaration universelle des
droits de l'homme
ce qu'ils ont imaginé la voulait
qu'universelle il y avait tout à l'heure
au tour de françois mitterrand
quatorze chefs d'état d'afrique 5
représentait l'asie
cette l'europe et 6 l'amérique dominique
derda article 1er les hommes naissent et
demeurent libres et égaux en droits les
distinctions sociales ne peuvent être
fondées que sur l'utilité commune
le symbole côte-à-côte 34 chefs d'état
de pays riches des pauvres réunissent
pour commémorer le bicentenaire de la
révolution française et de la
déclaration universelle des droits de
l'homme dit cet article entrecoupé de
texte donne politique de la révolution
librement
tous les peuples
ou presque tous ceux qui ont secoué le
joug de leurs tyrans sont arrivés à la
démocratie et sylvie ont presque
toujours aussi trouvé leur perte
ce que jamais il ne s'est trouvé des
hommes assez pur pour bien organiser
mais aujourd'hui nous planons à la face
de l'univers et les générations futures
trouveront leur gloire dans ce décret
nous proclamons la liberté universelle
m
à 24 heures de l'ouverture du sommet des
pays les plus industrialisés quatre
présidents de pays du sud ont donc dit à
monsieur mitterrand organisé nous un
autre sommet nord sud celui là le chef
de l'état français est d'accord les
détails avec vous georges bortoli sur
cette façon qu'ont les pays du sud
d'interférer dans le sommet des sept
il s'agit d'une idée nouvelle et donc
d'un fait nouveau
vous avez vu qu'à l'occasion de ce
bicentenaire monsieur mitterrand a
favorisé jusqu'à présent des rencontres
entre représentants des pays du nord et
des pays du sud des pays riches et des
pays pauvres s'ils préféraient des
rencontres de simple rencontre
informelle or ce dont il s'agit
maintenant c'est d'une réunion en forme
d'un sommet nord-sud et monsieur
mitterrand a dit qu'il y était favorable
alors ça ne veut pas dire qu'au cours du
présent sommet des sept
on va décider que le prochain sommet sur
un sommet nord-sud qu'il aura lieu à
telle date c'était un nom ça irait trop
vite
disons que l'idée a pris son départ mais
que le chemin sera long car il reste
notamment à monsieur mitterrand à
convaincre il embauche par exemple
madame chercheurs qui sont notoirement
moins favorable que le président
français à une institutionnalisation du
dialogue nord sud habituellement
l'elysée est un palais présidentiel
aujourd'hui il avait des allures de
ruche les bureaux les salles ont été
prêtés aux hôtes de marque pour un
gigantesque chassé croisé diplomatique
on a beaucoup donné dans le tête à tête
chacun profitant de ce bicentenaire pour
plaider sa cause notamment les plus
pauvres
michel mompontet paris rennes du monde
ou plutôt la diplomatie mondiale durant
six heures en effet un marathon 24
rencontres internationales entre
mariniers l'elysée pour tous une
obsession les 8600 milliards de francs
de la dette mondiale
9h ce matin dans le bureau présidentiel
de l'elysée rajiv gandhi et mitterrand
premier face-à-face l'inde en priorité
comme en urgence avec ses 300 milliards
de francs de dettes
mais malgré la gravité de cette dette
pas plus d'une demi-heure d'entretien
entre eux c'est la règle imposée à tous
immédiatement après toujours dans ce
bureau présidentiel benazir butto et le
pakistan là-bas 216 milliards de francs
de dettes et la montée de l'intégrisme
et chiite comme un péril supplémentaires
simultanément à deux pas dans le grand
salon de marigny madame akino reçoit
jacques delors le président philippin a
déjà reçu hier 350 millions de francs
des investisseurs français n attend
avant demain le triple sa dette à elle
c'est la ville est vrai à 350 milliards
de francs et sur ses deux hectares
parisien durant toute la journée un
rythme effréné
les consultations vont se succéder
consultation presque au sens médical du
terme entre des patients souffrant tous
d'un même mal la dette et des médecins
que l'on appelle ici des pays riches
conférence nord sud
le mot était donc sur toutes les lèvres
jusqu'à ce que quatre pays du
tiers-monde le réclament
en fin d'après midi george bush
remettait symboliquement et les pieds de
la prison de la bastille et 200 ans
après au président mitterrand le
président mitterrand qui a déjà répondu
ce soir aux pays pauvres
oui il a répondu oui à apporter son
soutien personnel à la tenue d'une
conférence nord-sud
il lui reste désormais entraînée dans ce
sens les autres chefs d'état chefs
d'état des pays riches
bien sûr la redistribution entre les
pays riches et les pays pauvres
l'environnement ce sont deux des thèmes
sur lesquels insiste justement helmut
kohl le chancelier ouest-allemand qu'a
rencontré aujourd'hui christine ockrent
une exclusivité antenne 2 bonsoir
monsieur renseignez vous représentez ici
à paris là des pays les plus riches du
monde pour le sommet a distrait mise et
la coïncidence avec l'anniversaire de la
révolution française
est ce que ça vous semble embarrassant
non pas du tout d'une famille afin de
conserver la révolution française c'est
une grande part aux sales histoires avec
des conséquences
mais aussi des conséquences moins
positifs les droits de l'homme la
paillette franchissement des océans
également les droits de l'homme les
droits du citoyen des libertés du
citoyen ceci s'est propagée jusque dans
matrix mme c'est donc je n'ai à cet
égard aucun complexe et cela ne
m'apparaît pas comme étant complexe le
monde s'est rétréci
enfin se réunissent this it et chefs
d'état d'afrique d'amérique qu'elle
acting nation les grands pays
industrialisés et ceci montre bien
qu'elle est la nature des problèmes et
ce sont des gens que vous rencontrez en
dehors des grandes cérémonies
collectives et déjà rencontré toute une
série de chine est là aujourd'hui
le grand problème est celui de la tête
c'est essentiel à l'ordre du jour du
sommet des pays en utilisant un pays où
il y sommes devons à trouver des
solutions nous devons fonder notre
contribution qu'il réalise et isole les
plus une envie ou non les situation est
meilleure cette somme il faut que ceux
qui sont dans une situation très
difficile pour lui que ça prenne à ses
débuts mais ils doivent trouver leur
propre volonté
à force de décision politique je veux
pour donner à kuta d'évolution y aller
dans la bonne direction
il ne sert à rien de ne faire que donner
de l'argent mais il faut que ceux qui
reçoivent cet argent convenablement
l'investissent la willow fait celle
d'être facile à dire mais d'un point de
vue psychologique c'est très difficile à
mettre en oeuvre
parmi les autres priorités de ce sommet
il ya les problèmes de l'environnement
et de l'écologie est ce que l'allemagne
fédérale ne risque pas d'être dans une
position difficile à cause des centrales
thermiques al membres
en faisant plus que d'autres en europe
mais c'est un problème qui est je viens
de m'entretenir avec le président du
brésil
l'environnement n'est plus une question
purement relationnel vous vous les
allemands vous poser aussi un problème
notamment en ce qui concerne le co2 avec
des centrales thermiques qui sont plus
polluantes que par exemple les centrales
nucléaires bien sûr mais ces dernières
années nous avons consenti des efforts
ou tenues considérable en montante et
les vitres électriques qui avait un
énorme extrêmement sévère si ces normes
allemandes été repris dans toute la
communauté européenne il aurait un grand
progrès de réalisés
est ce que vous êtes favorable monsieur
sont ceux liés à une politique
d'assistance financière envers les pics
d'europe de l'est
le président bush que l'on revient va
sans doute essayer de pousser sont
propositions la chose importante à dire
ici c'est l'intérêt de tous et surtout
l'intérêt des allemands c'est que le
produit laviolette démocrate d'ouverture
une politique pour plus de démocratie
plus de droits de l'homme et des faits
rien que cette politique soit couronnée
de succès et l'exemple de la chine nous
montre l'enquêté retour de manivelle
sont toujours possibles
ça fait parler de la visite d'un
président il faut que j'aie beaucoup de
bologne connaissait le sujet
l'éthique de réformer ce succès ne
viendra pas si les libertés politiques
qu'on qu'ils ne sont pas associés à
succès économique un progrès comme une
île pendant qu'une s'interroger sur les
possibilités est en train de négocier
avec la personne que nous arriverons à
lui à une solution globale et cela
également avec nos autres partenaires
occidentaux
d'après les tout derniers sondages en
france votre pays l'allemagne fédérale
est aux yeux des français
lasnier le plus sûr est ce que c'est pas
un peu paradoxal au moment où on
s'inquiète aussi de ce que beaucoup
appellent la dérive
une allemande vers l'est si la classe
politique parle d'une dérive de
l'allemagne eh bien ceux qui disent cela
ne connaissent pas bien la réalité
nous appartenons à l'occident ou
autrement dit nous ne sommes pas des
promeneurs entre deux mondes
nous ne restons pas assis entre deux
chaises nous l'avons fait deux fois ce
siècle et cela suffit liberté du citoyen
liberté de l'homme et elle est également
notre profession de foi pour l'avenir
démocratique mais c'est sain c'est
désormais si demain dans le journal de
13h claude sérillon et gérard carreyrou
interrogeront françois mitterrand
l'entretien sera diffusé sur antenne 2
ipf à l'étranger fidel castro n'a pas
été sensible aux appels à la clémence du
pape jean paul ii les quatre hauts
responsables militaires condamnés pour
trafic de drogue ont été fusillés à
l'aube isabelle de lieux le général
ochoa fuyez à l'aube à cuba ainsi que
trois hauts dirigeants militaires tous
condamnés à mort pour trafic de drogue
autre choix fut l'un des plus proches
conseillers de fidel castro et le
commandant des troupes cubaines en
angola
le président cubain a jugé extrêmement
grave qu'un héros de la république
puisse être si corrompu et a rejeté tous
les appels à la clémence
autre choix et ses collègues ont reconnu
avoir collaboré avec le cartel de
medellin le plus important réseau de
trafiquants au monde
de manifestants chinois exécuté accusés
d'avoir pris part au mouvement pour la
démocratie en chine
ils ont été condamnés pour avoir allumé
des incendies par ailleurs un ouvrier de
42 ans xiao ping a été condamné à 10 ans
de prison
témoins de la répression du printemps de
pékin il avait déclaré dans une
interview à la télévision américaine que
l'armée avait fait des milliers de morts
sur la place tiananmen la salle mandela
appelle le gouvernement sud africain a
négocié avec la haine c'est le congrès
national africain et tous les partis
d'opposition noir c'est selon lui le
seul moyen de mettre fin à la violence
et de rétablir la paix en afrique
cet appel du lit comme moi free suite à
sa rencontre historique de mercredi
dernier avec le président pieter botha
d'autre part nelson mandela a précisé
que sa remise en liberté ce n'était pas
d'actualité
deux informations complémentaires ce
soir au dîner de gala du musée d'orsay
le chef du congrès national africain
lines et on vient de vous en parler
la principale organisation de lutte
contre l'apartheid sud africain est
convié oliver tambo est l'invité
surprise
george bush et margaret thatcher
considéré il ya peu la haine c'est comme
une organisation terroriste
la france va octroyer un prêt
gouvernemental de 830 millions de francs
à la chine
aux termes d'un accord conclu cette
semaine c'est ce que dit en tout cas
l'agencé chine nouvelle
de source diplomatique française à pékin
on dément précisant qu'il s'agit là de
la mise en oeuvre d'un accord conclu
avant le gel des relations
gouvernementales entre paris et pékin
près de vichy la rocambolesque évasion
de trois malfaiteurs ils ont blessé un
gendarme prix est relâché plusieurs
otages
ils viennent de disparaître à nouveau
après soixante kilomètres qu'ils ont
parcourus dans une charrette à foin
déguisés en paysans sur place pour
antenne 2 aurélie c'est dans la matinée
à 30 km de roanne près du village de
marcigny au lieu dit les ménard que les
trois fuyards camoufle sous la paille
la fiat ils ont dérobé quelques heures
auparavant à deux pas une ferme où il se
cache en attendant son propriétaire
quand ce dernier arrive accompagné d'un
proche il les braquer les oblige à
quitter les lieux en tracteur attelé
d'une remorque bourré de paille deux des
gangsters si dissimuleront l'autre va
monter aux côtés de l'agriculteur allant
jusqu'à lui emprunter veste et casquette
l'étrange équipe et qui donc ainsi la
ferme à travers la campagne pendant
qu'une cinquantaine de kilomètres entre
marcigny et bi zoua sans être inquiétés
ou presque puisqu'il passe trois
barrages de gendarmes qui quadrillent le
périmètre tout le temps sans relâche
depuis 48 heures à bize oui ils libèrent
leurs otages et volt aussitôt deux taxis
c'est là en direction de vichy que l'on
perd leur trace
c'est le brigadier roland pinsard le
premier des otages de cette folle cavale
qui se libèrent sol et donne l'alertent
dès 5h ce matin ce sont bien les deux
évadés de la prison 10 heures et un
complice il a passé de 38 heures
d'angoissé entre leurs mains les
dernières dans cette ferme où les trois
hommes le sait qu'être en compagnie des
propriétaires
trois personnes âgées dans les premières
heures oui j'ai craint pour ma vie mais
après ça a été
il avait l'air nerveux très anxieux
aux premières heures de l'attaqué mais
après il a au fil des heures non se sont
calmées mois mangeant les liens mais
malgré une fouille minutieuse des termes
de cette région boisée où les étangs
sont si nombreux malgré l'importance des
forces sur le terrain 400 gendarmes et
deux hélicoptères les trois gangsters
spécialiste de la cavale ont pu
finalement passer à travers les mailles
du plan vautours luxe yole dans le doubs
a littéralement été décimés par la
démence meurtrière de christian dornier
14 morts pour un village de 140
habitants
les victimes seront inhumées vendredi
sur place pour antenne 2 emmanuel
vanille et gilles ragon un colosse
taciturne solitaire dépressif c'est
christian dornier le meurtrier décrit
par les villageois
un jeune homme renfermé qui avait même
refusé samedi dernier d'assister au
mariage de sa soeur sa première victime
c'est d'ailleurs peut-être un différend
familial qui est à l'origine de sa crise
de folie meurtrière depuis plusieurs
semaines des villageois avait senti la
tension monte
christian dornier avait même tiré des
coups de feu contre un voisin il ne
conseil municipal avait alors choisi de
ne pas alerter la gendarmerie
s'il ya encore du monde pourra peut-être
nous dire ce qu'il en était vraiment
dans les temps d'avant
je pense qu'il y avait un problème caché
il faut pas qu'ils reviennent sinon je
vous garantis que les habitants
linchamps il détruire ou qui se voir si
c'est pas possible je le dirai en haut
lieu mais il faut que qui va parler
jamais je mets luxe yole un village
traumatisés comme tétanisés par ce drame
ce matin peu de monde dans les rues
pas de manifestations violentes pas de
cris de haine la douleur ici et me met
discrète comme le village lui même caché
au coeur de la forêt le drame a été
comme effacés seuls restaient ce matin
ce vélo d'une des petites victimes
cet après-midi le lent défilé des
familles et des amis venus s'incliner
sur les cercueils dans la mairie
transformée en chapelle ardente
moi je veux parler voir les victimes
parce que je pourrais pas donc pas
supporter ça va il n'a pas fermé l'oeil
7 mai puis je pense qu'au village pas
beaucoup de leurs comptes
cool romoeren ce soir le village et de
nouveaux déserts comme si les habitants
redoutaient de sortir et d'être à
nouveau confronté dans les rues au
souvenir du drame
les obsèques des 14 victimes auront lieu
demain toutes les fêtes du 14 juillet
ont été annulés à lux yole demain ce
sera le silence la tristesse et le
recueillement
les quatre dirigeants d'action directe
en sont à 85 jours de grève de la faim
il réclame je vous le rappelle la
suspension des mesures d'isolement
leur avocat a déclaré aujourd'hui que
leurs clients sont en train de mourir
dans les prisons françaises au ministère
de la justice leur état de santé est
suivi de très près la chancellerie
souligne également que des contacts ont
été établis la semaine dernière avec les
grévistes qui ont accepté de recevoir
des médecins en contrepartie ils ont
reçu du ministère l'assurance d'être
placés dans des cellules rapprocher
l'actualité en france marquée également
par l'apaisement dans le conflit de la
météo
claire chazal fin de la grève durait
depuis six semaines à la météorologie
nationale
fo et la cfdt ont signé cet après midi
au ministère des transports un protocole
d'accord prévoyant notamment une
amélioration des carrières et le
relèvement des certaines indemnités
de renault ont rencontré le médiateur
pour la première fois ce matin jean
lavergne qui avait déjà vu la direction
de la régie mardi à écouter la cgc mais
a seulement proposé une prochaine
rencontre lundi prochain à 9h
cinq et quatre ans de prison et dix ans
d'interdiction de séjour pour les deux
basques militants présumés de letea
militaire un qu'une feuille dans la
sphère de la socoa dans les sous sols de
cette société les policiers avaient
trouvé en novembre 86 un important stock
d'armes et de munitions deux autres
prévenus le pdg et le directeur général
de la société ont été relaxés les deux
policiers responsables de la bavure de
six fours dans le var au cours de
laquelle un jeune automobiliste avait
été blessé à l'épaule ont été libérés et
placés sous contrôle judiciaire
ils restent inculpés de coups et
blessures volontaires donné dans
l'exercice de leurs fonctions la femme
de service licencié d'un foyer de
personnes âgées de saint saulve dans le
nord pour avoir volé deux artichauts et
réintégré après jugement aux prud'hommes
bicentenaire suite
toutes ces cérémonies ont commencé à
drainer beaucoup de piétons dans les
rues de la capitale on attend par
exemple demain soir près d'un million de
spectateurs pour le défilé planétaire de
jean paul goude pour les services de
sécurité il ya là un véritable casse
tête comment gérer les foules
la réponse avec richard biner une foule
c'est comme un fleuve on peut la
contrôler à sa source et à canaliser la
détourner jamais l'arrêter
le soir du 14 juillet plus d'un million
de personnes tentent d'approcher le
chant jean paul goude pas de barrières
anti foule mais un dispositif tout en
souplesse
articulé autour de trois règles premiers
principes établis au dos de chaque site
à périmètre de sécurité si un incident
éclate
si la pression de la foule
dangereusement on peut couper
l'alimentation en parant les voies
d'accès second principe compartimentée
la foule
c'est la technique du morcellement
imaginer que nous connaissions un
incident extrêmement grave sur un
secteur on peut dire qu'il cela évite la
propagation du phénomène
l'ondé de choc sur une foule souvenez
vous des images de l'enterrement de
l'ayatollah khomeiny où on a vu ces
vagues successives qui s'emparait de la
pour éviter un drame de type ce field
troisième principe maintenir la foule à
distance des sites où elle ne doit pas
accéder est bien connu qu'il ya un
principe fondamental en psychologie des
foules c'est que plus l'objectif est
proche plus la foulée dynamique et plus
l'objectif est prenable et à ce moment
là il est certain que l'on peut subir
des pressions auxquelles personne ne
peut résister pas même des grilles
extrêmement solide aussi la place de la
concorde où seront accueillis les
officiels sera protégé par un large sas
de filtrage
seuls les riverains et les invités
seront autorisés à pénétrer à
l'intérieur de cette zone
le jour de la grande parade de toute
façon ce sera la bousculade
cet après midi les pompiers de paris ont
dressé trois hôpitaux de campagne
ici aux abords des champs elysées dans
la salle du jeu de paume il considère
qu'une personne sur 1000 sera victime
d'un malaise
on rencontre assez fréquemment des
crises d'hypoglycémie qui seront dus au
fait que les gens ont attendu très
longtemps par trois debout sans
s'alimenter sans s'hydrater on trouve
également des crises de tétanie
fréquente chez les femmes en particulier
lorsqu'elles sont dans ce type de
situation de full d'inquiétude un peu
d'angoissé et enfin on peut rencontrer
des malaises
nettement plus grave des malaises de
type cardiaque par exemple a vaincu
d'une low carb entre autres tous les
hôpitaux de paris sont en état d' alerte
900 ambulanciers infirmiers médecins
sont prêts à intervenir dans ces trois
hôpitaux de campagne complété par 19
postes de secours pour que rien ne
vienne troubler la révolution good un
délire planétaire se raconte pas ça se
voit notamment sur antenne 2 en direct
demain soir mais voici un avant-goût
d'ci on peut dire les très mauvais je
sais du défilé version non militaire
qu'a concocté jean paul goude c'est
george v go et des cameramen breux est
d'avis qu'ils ont espionné la répétition
ce défilé est étonnant qui emprunte au
carnaval et au magic circus produit une
très forte impression dans les idées
sont hardy et les moyens colossaux
ce spectacle d'un soir couple 98
millions de francs près de 10 milliards
de centimes
l'équivalent du budget de cinq
disciplines de long métrage met quand on
aime on ne compte pas et l'on peut
penser que le public se réjouira de voir
réunis dans une fête colorée tous les
peuples de la planète
au nom des droits de l'homme
l'opéra good mêle l'humour à
l'esthétisme moderne on sent que le
metteur en scène vient du monde de la
publicité ou toute image doit frapper au
premier coup d'oeil provoqué le
spectateur par son originalité des
tambours des tambours goode m les
tambours il y en a de toutes sortes
venus du fin fond de l'afrique
d'amérique ou tout simplement de
provence d'auvergne par les régions
françaises sont également à l'honneur
moment d'émotion moins bruyants
l'apparition des chinois gageons que ces
étudiants recueilleront la sympathie et
les bravos les plus chaleureux le clou
de la soirée fait allusion au célèbre
film de jean renoir la bête humaine dans
lequel gabin conduisait une locomotive
avec gabin les cheminots c'est la france
populaire qui s'imposent au final
et comme vienne me souffle et laurent
cabrol il n'y aura pas demain sur les
champs-elysées une goutte de pluie
évidemment le tour de france l'étape du
jour 242 km entre toulouse et
montpellier a été marquée par plusieurs
incidents des chutes d'abord celle de
chez perse ou encore de devenir ou entre
autres il ya également eu des
manifestations sur le parcours et des
manifestants peu amènes jacques chancel
a par exemple eu le nez cassé la course
elle a été très belle trois hommes ont
réussi une très belle échappée tebaldi
périgny et dominique arnaud ce dernier
est tombé à 20 kilomètres de l'arrivée
ils auront ces trois hommes jusqu'à 30
minutes d'avancé sur le peloton et 22
minutes à l'arrivée pour le vainqueur
tebaldi fignon est toujours en jaune
voilà l'arrivée formule 1 c'est
l'autrichien gerhard bergen qui
remplacera prost dans l'écurie mclaren
la saison prochaine il y avait un tiercé
quarté + cet après-midi yang
voici la combinaison gagnante le pari
car tu es un 14 11 9
le pari tiers c'est un 14 11 et il ya
également deux mains tiercé quarté + à
saint cloud avec douze partants et donc
des pronostics de pierrette brès le dise
le 4 le 11 le 2 le 1 le 8 le 9 et de
sète demain matin télématin sachez que
gérard morin dans les 4 vérités recevra
michel vovelle qui est historien qui a
donc écrit de nombreux de nombreux
ouvrages sur la révolution c'est le jour
ou jamais dans un instant vous avez
rendez vous avec la météo dernier
journal sur antenne 2 ce soir c'est bien
sûr henri sannier pour ma part je
retrouve je vous retrouve demain à 20
heures
excellente soirée à touches sur antenne
2 vous allez dans un instant à l'opéra
bastille
t
non